taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them already
yeah great
I'm so dehydrated hey
taste I got water taste buddies this is
all in
start with I'm so dehydrated I'm serious
start with I'm hydrated taste buddy he's
welcome too
t-a-s-d-e Buzz lead with a complaint
I'm very dehydrated I went uh to the
Juneteenth celebration last night in
Central Park okay uh very spur of the
moment to the summer stage
um
and I I'm hydrated I got to see I just
cursed
I got to see how great is this I got to
see Grandmaster Flash and DJ Premiere do
DJ sets oh was that the hip-hop 50 now
honestly it was for Juneteenth yeah it
was really really cool it was super fun
but uh you know we had a few pops while
we were there and okay I did not drink
enough water and we were outside and I'm
a little too high and then I never ate
dinner so I ate pizza late
I did everything basically except for
attending the event wrong okay you know
but it was fun who'd you go with uh it
was last minute Paul
Joey roses Paul uh was like um
he's like hey man this thing's this
event's happened
uh
I don't know if it was free or not or if
he just had I don't know he just said
hey
do you want to go to this and I went up
with uh Ari came with us it was fun oh
cool it was really fun all right yeah
well we just got off a vacation
we did just off a vacation then straight
into the road I've seen a lot of you
dude I know this is like we went
together for seven or eight days then
one day down then three days on the road
then one then one day down and today so
and then I'm sitting here Thursday
that's 14 14 days I've seen you 12 of
them
yeah I'm gonna I mean tap out soon
myself
I mean it's been a lovely run for
anybody it's a lot it's it's
been a lovely run there's no listener
what are you saying I'm just talking to
the listeners it's a new thing I do now
it's just for the listener it's a little
segment I call just for the list now
what's that hey babe thing what no not
at all oh okay it's uh JFL I'm doing a
JFL real quick
been a little bit overwhelmed oh being
with him with 12 out of 14 days and I
think that despite me being any no if I
could be you know his best friend in the
world it doesn't matter it's just too
much the dose is too high at DeRosa and
I think that no matter who you are
you'll be looking for an hour at this
point so I'm going to do that today I'm
going to do a couple of episodes and I'm
gonna do the best I can and then we
actually have to go to the listeners
anything positive what did you say
anything positive but you know it's nice
to have friends like that it's nice to
have friends like that I heard that all
right was it a positive story or
negative no I just was saying that how
I've seen you too much and and it
doesn't matter who you are you can't see
someone that much and I'm gonna need a
break after tonight's concert I might
not go tonight great that's the break
starts earlier uh I actually we're
supposed to go are you really not can I
say on air what yeah I can say because
this is after yeah it doesn't matter
well you got us tickets to see the Cure
tonight yes I did
uh
I can't think of a bigger pendulum swing
in music events from Juneteenth with
Grandmaster Flash and DJ Premiere to The
Cure
like
like emotional like this video it's just
funny like like awesome
party celebratory hip-hop
exuding confidence
strength
to the cure for guys moping around the
stage wailing
melodically wailing
dreary
look I know
eight nine Cure songs that I really love
I looked at the set list already
I know I they don't even turn up to like
the popular ones until the second Encore
but like I just saw love cats on there I
love love cats it's not on the set list
so I mean you know out of the three
albums I have they Place selections from
one of those albums okay it's heavy
albums I don't have yeah uh and no it's
also a what you got to do here is get on
board it's a three-hour show it's a
three yeah Daddy Walsh went and he said
it was amazing and he was like I
strongly urge you to go he goes it's a
three-hour show but yeah but that's with
the opener isn't it but here's the thing
here's the thing
if I don't go tonight I know I'm out the
ticket which seems like a loss but I got
an offer from Paul once again to go
tomorrow night and sit in a sky box with
an open bar and free food and I'm like
well if I don't go tonight I can cash in
on that wow wow there you have it this
is kind of like you know getting to know
Joe even more today that's all you need
to hear
it's not about friendship or or that's
better we have pretty good seats we have
great seats we're in section 108 it's
good good seats I don't even want to ask
how much do these tickets I don't know I
actually don't know they didn't tell you
no I had to like I guess wait till the
charge hits I mean it's probably like
those seats nowadays or anybody you go
there for a couple hundred bucks maybe I
don't know you know you got them for
your agents you'd think your agents say
it's on the Army you're a good earner
who'd you get it from I bought him he
just bought them well I I got I get the
Live Nation section access to that yeah
but I pay for them no no you pay but I'm
saying like you can't get those you have
to get those through meaning to buy
connections at the Garden we have a
section right but you're getting them at
face value they're not most value
okay I thought your agents were getting
you them at face value no if my agents
were getting me them I would hope they'd
be free well that's why I made the joke
of you're a good earner kid and this kid
is a good earner
because I ca we came back from our seven
day vacation that that Sal apparently
just quietly told all the listeners was
a horror show because he had to be
around me for seven days I didn't say
that I mean it's you know you didn't
hear what it was said in the JFL it
wasn't anything positive you got to stop
calling it JFL you're going to get sued
by JFL the festival the biggest they
don't have a hold on letters really yeah
it's an acronym it's called gfl yeah I
mean
NWA you wouldn't just run into problems
just to listen us WWF had to change
their name to WWE because of the
Wildlife Foundation no yes no it's
because they they
no they went to entertainment
no that they did that because I'm dead
serious The Wildlife Foundation
you know that right I'm not sure I do
yeah the the they like they got into
like the wildlife the World Wildlife
Foundation yeah it's called the WWF and
like there was they they complained
about that a little late in the game now
I bet you it's WWF for a decade
uh after the World Wildlife Fund
I bet you that that that legal fight was
going on for 30 years and they finally
won I don't think that that was like an
overnighter well I JFL in this context
is something new I'm coining it's gonna
be a new segment on the show when I need
an aside just to The Listener you're
gonna run into problems I'm not gonna
run into anything uh I went out with you
after I would this is what I was going
to say pimp and I'll say it out loud
because I'm proud
and I'll say to everybody I don't need
to whisper anything
I have been with Sal for the last 13
days we haven't had one argument not one
argument I would say not even a tense
moment
the most tense moment we had was we were
in the pool at one point and I pitched
you an idea for a reality show where you
where a married couple has to stay in a
house full of Bachelors and he wasn't
that into it and
[Laughter]
I mean give me the give me the Meeks
tell me how it's sustaining tell me how
it's producible what am I watching
there's no writer strike yeah there you
go exactly
good point I already got it immediately
Ari came out mid conversation and he
goes where's the show but this is the
this is this is why I like Ari he goes
what are you guys talking about I go I'm
pitching him an idea this is why I like
Ari Ari comes out he goes what are you
talking about and I said I'm talking
about this
I I've been a bachelor my whole life all
right and I can't tell you how many
times I go to an event or something and
it's a bunch of couples and I go I don't
want to be the only single person and
all the couples go oh no we're not those
kind of whatever right and I said so I
have an idea for a reality show I go you
take a married couple and Ari goes and
put him in a house full of bachelor's
yes that's that's awesome and I was like
you get it my friend this guy holy cow
what's the show he's going how is it how
do you monetize this how do you I mean
this whoa Jesus geez Louise
we almost lost him for good
holy cow
for those for those of you that home
that don't know what just happened
because you can't see it obviously pimp
has put up uh Asian uh dressing those
folding things it's literally literally
poster board but it look it's it's in
this fashion like a scrim maybe yeah is
that what that's called a scrim I
believe so uh it looks like something a
ninja would get stressed behind he put
up Asian it's literally white poster
board I know I'm making the joke of yeah
well a way to go with it
see nothing like there's a woman
changing behind it we see her silhouette
and then she turns out to be half dragon
it's some weird reveal the uh um
anyway we we had a great time uh uh
uh and there was never it was never
really a tense I don't think no but the
show I I need to know
what what the show is I can't just sign
off and on a broad idea I'll Circle I'll
Circle back I'll Circle back
or as I said in the pool put a pin in
there I'll take it to q and get it made
[Laughter]
listen you can you can throw me a
hundred ideas but I want to help you
have an idea that gets picked up and
stays on the air I hear you you know
what I'm saying I'm asking the questions
that I could care I'm going for a cash
grab in and out let me get it let me get
it fast it sounds like you guys are
having a great pride month
[Music]
I'm always with you during Pride now
that I think about it yeah yeah because
I remember the last few Pride months uh
you were like we always do the fried
shirts somewhere it's eventful do you
guys think you could actually have a
relationship romantically
him and I yeah what does that mean in
this in the physical sense no I can't be
physical with him no you wouldn't do
that no no it's not for me
I think I could I mean guys I mean him
no no no no no no I I couldn't I
couldn't be romantically involved with a
man
I I don't I don't think I could love you
for who you are as a person
really
oh just kidding I know you can
you kid I'm literally going with the
flow all right fair enough uh
I could I no I could not be sexual with
him but uh that's even weird just to
hear him say it but uh I do think I
could live with you
in a companion sense
I think I think we would actually be
quite good for each other
I think we would have a nice balance out
and we have enough crossover in the neat
Department
and in the OCD Department that I think
I could not live with a slop your
roommate I'm as I'm as neat I'm I'm
paying I'm insanely organized yeah uh
like so I think we would get along very
well in the domestic sense I think we
we'd have a lot of things we like to
watch together I think we'd have a lot
of laughs okay
I like to cook
you know I think this could work
well I don't love being like very
stressed out all the time so for those
Reasons I'm out
I would think that you would you would
take that and say I could emotionally
support you as being somebody who cooks
for me yeah no I was I made a shark tank
joke oh is that a shark tractor yeah I
don't watch it oh you should
not for me that's in syndication that's
in its 12 13 to 15 season
do you think they went in there and
they're like let me just explain
something to you we sit in a chair
well that's what they did do you know
what I don't like about it I don't like
the element of
I don't like how candid the sharks are
about how wealthy they are I think that
becomes kind of gross after a while
I'm like I watched the one well I
watched no I watched the one Shark Tank
guy on smartless
and he's a human yeah and he tells the
story of like I don't know his name
Mark Cuban like that's his real name
it's like a wrestler okay uh you know so
anyway but I I uh watch people get
actually will get mad in the comments
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know and he's like he's like he's
like gleefully telling the story of like
the day he became a billionaire and
watch I know but it's like it's just a
little there's a lot of that I feel like
on Shark Tank where it's not in there is
it's not in dull it's not indulgent but
there's a lot of
I've made a lot of money and I know
money and I know and it's like okay yeah
I don't need to hear this okay well then
don't watch it I'm not gonna force you
to watch it thank you I've Loved I think
it's fantastic I know you do it's it's I
like the lady I like the blonde lady
Barbara Corcoran I don't know any of
their names so she's cork in real estate
she's great
she's great No Nonsense doesn't need to
impress anybody you don't know Lori
Lori's awesome which one's Lori he's
queen of QVC don't know Lori I mean if I
saw her I don't know maybe I'll watch
the person with another shot it's not my
type of TV
Shark Tank okay you know I like it
because you can put it on at any time
pick up wherever you are you could watch
stuff again and forget what happened
it's very repeatable and honestly every
single one of them is is interesting you
just it's really it just doesn't get old
it's like cooking shows to me I don't
know why I love them so much but I could
watch certain people cook or cooking
conversations over and over and over it
just does it's just the perfect like on
in the background kind of like you know
and then there's I don't know that and
and each each
pitch is like its own thing it's it's
digestible it's like five six minutes
and you have a whole beginning middle
and end you take you're on a wild ride
it gets emotional you know they're just
as much sometimes profiles on people
than anything else and then I love the
the actual strategies between the Sharks
and and and seeing them fight and and I
you know it has all the right
ingredients for a hit show you don't
feel like it's like a byproduct of like
corporate greed and the in perpetuity
contracts that's that's what I mean I
feel it I feel like there's a little bit
of those things exist in perpetuity
contracts and it's up to them whether
they feel it's the right fit for them or
not still all like it still will boost
your business acumen
that I get but
yeah I don't know it's it's there's
still you know what it is negotiating
here's what it is it's it's good to see
I don't know I don't think it's
fascinating I don't think it's I I
disagree with you there I do not think
it's a great lesson in negotiating I
think it's a lesson in high-powered
negotiating and I don't think that
that's applicable to most people and I
think that I think that it's a very take
it or leave it Vibe a lot of the time
which people who I am one who very much
want to kick start a mom-and-pop dream
product or store whatever I I don't
think that's always the best way to be
the best position being that said
they're going involuntarily I'm not
saying anybody's being taken advantage
of anything but I agree with pimp and I
think pimp you put your finger on it
it's not that they're it's not that
they're gloating in their wealth I just
feel like it's a micro Cosmic uh example
of America and this mentality we have of
like you're not successful unless you
hit this dollar number and I think that
that's a very toxic it feels like almost
like you get that at all it feels like
big pirate ships pulling up to a good
idea to rob it of its
um I don't know man I I mean you don't
get you watch many success stories you
also I believe the posting associations
are still the same no matter what but
the success stories are based in units
dollars you know what I mean it's never
well it's business it's retail it's it's
selling a product of service I get that
but there's a lot of there are a lot of
tears to success sure and a product and
so and I don't like that the only
version of success with shark tank is if
you don't sell this many million you're
a failure and it's not worth my time
it's not really that though I mean
that's just that's a general
business belief I'm sure I think it's a
bad belief yeah is what I'm saying I
like it I listen I don't I take that
back I don't necessarily think it's a
bad
I want to be careful with my words here
I don't think it's a bad belief I think
it's bad to think that if you don't let
the Sharks hear you if you don't achieve
that you have failed that's what I think
but in I think in business you either
have to thrive or not
but but business could mean
I make a very same prioritize what you
see value in in life and and then that
this latch on to something where like
material and money
represents
value or importance I'm not saying that
but this is specifically about business
well it's about high-powered capitalism
business okay it's not about you would
never see a thing on Shark Tank where
they go it's a Licorice store and it
will make a hundred fifty thousand
dollars a year in profits and that will
be more than enough to support me and my
family and keep our tiny Board of
investors
do you see that though sometimes they'll
say look look you guys seem like you're
doing all the right things I don't know
what I could add to you you guys are
okay self-sustainable you should be
doing exactly what you're doing and you
can be very successful I have nothing to
add to you did I'm wrong yeah that I'm
wrong see I can admit I'm wrong you were
saying at the beginning of this though
that
you said that I
am a hard I don't know if you said hard
work you're about to say a thought so
you got a big earner good earner you
said at the end of we just did it and at
the end of the week yeah I said I said
you're a good earner because I went on
tour with the Jokers oh oh so all the
way down oh okay yeah all right I didn't
catch up I was saying they couldn't the
least that your agents could do is slip
your tickets yeah sorry believe that I
think I should have asked the uh what's
that maybe I should have asked yeah but
I'm just being funny no I'm saying but
maybe I should have asked maybe you
should have maybe they should have
offered is what I'm saying maybe there's
a gift basket when you get back from the
tour thanks for all you do
Arena number 77 down I mean we'll figure
it out I would I would send an email if
I were you yeah yeah
no um we went out I opened for you guys
for three shows
uh we had fun
I had a great time I hung out with you
and Q a ton it's so much fun I bonded a
lot with myrrh which was really nice
okay I didn't really know her
very well and I had a great time talking
to him I laughed with him a lot yeah um
and
um did you enjoy the crowds I had great
time on stage I was terrified I was
terrified I was thinking I probably
well I don't I don't here's why I don't
think I was overthinking it I think my
fear and anxiety is what
it was
two decades plus of stand-up comedy
going
this is not something you just Waltz out
and do get yours you have to have your
[__] together you have to have a plan of
attack you have to know how to do this
and if you don't do it the right way
you're not it's not going to go well
that is a hundred percent true okay with
that kind of show yeah it is not you're
in an arena you're going out in front of
uh an act that the audience is
positively rabid to see right there is
zero interest in anything that is
preventing them from getting to that
but that would make it sound like they
really they weren't rude chew you up and
spit yeah no they weren't rude they
weren't like they weren't like I'm not
saying like they would have booed you
right well no check the phone what I was
doing because you said to the arena so I
just want to say that July 27 28 29th is
the last weekend of the leg of this
Joker's tour right so it's Nashville
Indianapolis and St Louis on those dates
and then we're not touring again until
the second leg of the store until the
new year because I start to run again
solo because I'm shooting the special in
December in Chicago right right
so sometimes how you turn a personal
story that I'm trying to tell you into a
plug for yourself I thought it was
pretty good that is really just
incredible dude I know but yeah I'm an
artist no wonder you like Shark Tank
you're talking about me being an earner
I'm just plugging in playing the grand
old opera you got to come to that game
Bridge Fieldhouse you know the stifle
theater two shows St Louis 2017 tickets
available on impracticaljokerslive.com
right now
not to mention my soul dates going on
sale soon
another 20 cities through August and uh
August through November and then the big
one I chose you Chicago
to film my special on December 1st and
2nd December 2nd sorry at the Vic
theater so be on the lookout for that
because they're going to go fast and I
really want you then God bless and let's
just hold on I'm just doing a JFL real
quick uh it's okay I should check out
comedy.com for my solo dates
people saying how not funny this is all
right just just so you know yeah so you
know about the comments
they're not trying to be funny this is
just a way for me to talk to you and not
have to deal with the Fallout of his
temper
okay thank you did you just quietly plug
please tell me you didn't do that no I
didn't okay
uh
uh I would
maybe this is today is the tension that
wasn't happening
over the last two weeks that I've spent
with him maybe it's all just coming up
today finally factor is America's number
one ready to eat meal kit they're
helping you fuel up fast with flavorful
and nutritious Ready-to-Eat meals
delivered straight to your door
that means they're made already you get
them you uh microwave them for about two
minutes and that's it you're done all
you do is heat and then eat and then you
can go back outside or go back to the
bathtub I don't know if you get out of
the bathtub to eat but if you do this is
a good option for me uh maybe you just
need to take a quick break at work and
you want to eat something delicious and
and Hearty and worth uh eating and not
something junky and crappy like a lot of
microwave food is well factors giving
you quality food that you can eat very
quickly again two minutes that's all it
takes to heat this up
try delicious dietitian approved calorie
smart meals with around or less than 550
calories per serving if you need an
extra protein boost to support your
Wellness goals try the Protein Plus
meals option with 30 grams of protein or
more per serving you can elevate your
eating at home with the new upscale surf
and turf there's a surf and or there's
surf and turf there's Surf and surf meal
options I like that uh which you know
feature things like roasted garlic filet
mignon and shrimp or cajun spice shrimp
and salmon I love it it's delicious it's
flavor packed they've got vegan options
they've got veggie options it's it's any
whatever your lifestyle is there are 34
plus Chef prepared dietitian approved
weekly options so go to factor it's
great check it out head to
factormeals.com tastebuds50 use promo
code taste plus five zero to get 50 off
your first box that's code taste buds50
at factormeals.com taste buds five zero
so to get 50 off your first box Joe
DeRosa here to tell you about our
sponsor nuts
folks deal
shoes do you like gummy bears do you
like olives what about popcorn salt
water taffy trail mix sesame sticks
dried fruit my God the list goes on and
on and on nuts.com has it all I love
this place uh they're gonna let you get
those nuts for the quick snack on the go
you grab it on the way out the door
whatever you know uh
uh let's talk about the uh why you might
need the nuts 11 A.M feeling they call
it it's after breakfast it's not quite
lunch you've been eating healthy and
you're trying you know you don't want to
numb down as they say on a donut but
you're famished you feel like you need
something well you need something and it
should be something that's not a donut
not a cupcake not candy get yourself
something from nuts.com nuts.com your
One Stop Shop for freshly roasted nuts
dried fruit sweets they do have candy uh
Pantry Staples like specialty flowers
and more it's just a wide selection and
there's something for everybody I love
it so anyway right now nuts.com is
offering new customers a free gift with
purchase uh and and free shipping on
orders of 29 or more just go to nuts.com
taste buds check out all of the
delicious options at nuts.com taste buds
you'll receive a free gift and free
shipping when you spend 29 or more
that's nuts.com taste buds uh using
tensions you know what see what happens
here I just noticed that look at that
see that on the inside of your chair
right here see that black spot right
there on the inside yeah that's from
people doing this that's the floor
making the chair black on the side
because we put our legs up fascinating I
gotta hit that with like uh some type of
a cleaner like a 4M
or something it was a 3M 3M are you this
save this content for the solo tour put
like a I mean this is I want to put like
one of those things on it there for
stains and stuff
I mean I've seen the ACT
this is
more interesting you know what you don't
like my closing
you don't like my clothes are about the
shoes on the on the on the chair
um no no I don't think I over thought
that at all I think I think that it's a
it's a crowd rabid to see you guys and I
think that if you're going to postpone
them from seeing you for any period of
time you need to have your [__] together
sure that's true uh I thought you're
more worried about the content of your
well I was I was because you have there
are literal children in the audience
there are a few yeah well there there
were more than a few I mean it wasn't
like it wasn't five six well I don't
know it was a lot of people I mean it's
an arena so we suggests 16 plus but we
just suggest that and so sometimes
families come with their kids I also for
the I mean it's 99 99.5 or 99.9 it's
99.9 adults
um
thousands and thousands and thousands
five six kids
I know there's more than five or six I
would go out and look each night at the
audience when the lights were on it's
not a ton but the point is is there's
kids there sure so when you see kids
you think in fact when you think when I
was talking to Brian on the plane yeah
and I said I'm a little worried about
like this joke or that joke he said he
goes well there are kids there like it
wasn't something to not make a note of
um and it also was not the kind of
whether it was five kids or 15 or 100 or
whatever it doesn't matter it's still
not the kind of show where you can go
out and do anything goes material like
there's a certain type of material that
would work and there was a certain line
that if you crossed it would have been
too much I feel pretty I think that's
fair and that's not a bad thing it's
just what it is I just think she thought
the line was
well that is more strict than I was
because I I also because here's why the
second I see a kid or here kids will be
there
I forget that every kid wasn't raised
the way I was where like it's like
that's rated R is rated R is off limits
until you're like 13 or 14. Okay and
like you know your your mom is you know
turning the channel of things with foul
language and you know what I mean like
yeah
awkward thing when like you watch it
like a movie was on when I was little
and there's like a sex scene and you're
all watching as a family you're watching
something all of a sudden people are
banging they're just like it's still
it's still like I'll leave the room it's
like a sexy yeah it comes on when I'm
with my parents everyone's like everyone
just is kind of like
yeah it's very weird
um
yeah it was interesting I wanted to
watch the whale I'm gonna write that
down I wanted to watch the whale with my
mom okay
but I can't because there's
the first time you see Brendan Fraser's
character he's
furiously masturbating to gay
no like like spoiler alert like and it's
not that it's spoiler alert it's not
that it's gay
it's a masturbation scene it's it's it's
it's it's awkward I watched it on a
plane and I was like oh this is a little
awkward but what are you afraid of
I can't be in a room with my mom when
something like that comes on the
television I just can't handle it it's
too awkward to me it's just weird
it's you know call it a Catholic
upbringing whatever but so so and and my
mom would probably just be like all
right it's a little what are you gonna
you know what I mean like it's amazing
he was furiously masturbating no he's
did you use the word furious yes so how
what what denotes a furious masturbation
well that's just a term that people use
yes I understand but I'm saying I'm in
this in the in the in the film
it's a heavy
grunty masturbating that's happening and
did you singularize your masturbation
did you say it was a heavy grunty
masturbate I don't know is that what you
just said I don't know okay I don't know
I might have but it's a terrible word we
need a new word for it you know if the
word is off-putting right you know it is
masturbate masturbation it's just like I
don't know if it's
odd or so I don't know what what what it
calls up for me but I don't the word is
off-putting but here I am I did two
masturbation jokes in front of your
audience and they left but I thought
it'd be too much they weren't like dirty
jokes necessarily right they did one
about a I had to do a semen sample for
my doctor and uh you know I don't know I
just you you know I'm like can I say the
f word like you know I didn't know that
there was so let them fly sure but like
just going in I was nervous but I'm glad
I was nervous if I didn't it made me
take it like extra seriously and it made
it a great time it made it really
rewarding now we didn't tell oh until
like the second show we didn't tell
anyone that you were going to be there
did you get
like when it when you when you walked
out as when it was a surprise before we
announced it on socials I mean most of
the people didn't know you were gonna be
that um did you did you did you hear any
taste buddies fans in the audience I met
some after the shows and stuff like at
the end when you go up and say good
night yeah yeah I met some during that
part I I would say though
I mean and then some messaged me and
stuff but like it seems like the podcast
audience versus The Joker's audience
there's not a lot of there's not a ton
of crossovers okay I don't think I might
be wrong but it seems and it might be
very different for hey babe I don't know
but um
whereas with your stand-up solo shows
yeah
way more crossover yeah like way more
yeah but those were also much smaller
audiences
educating my television audience
of my comedy audience like you know what
I mean well that's the other thing I was
nervous about like when I'm going out
with you it's fans of you who are also
fans of the Jokers who are also fans of
taste buds who are also fans of these
other things but they're fans of you
first and I have a pretty close
association with you at this point yeah
the Jokers is its own entity
and I'm like for all I know half this
audience could be here because they love
myrrh you know what I mean and I have no
connection to him what's up you know I
don't know like how it works so it was
like it was just kind of a different
thing but it was awesome the crowds were
amazing I had a great time
it was so cool it was fun flexing that
muscle again I hadn't been in an arena
in a while
that's always fun when you go out and do
it and go oh I know how to do yeah stand
up like it's a different muscle yeah a
little bit
um and then but the best part we're
spending time with you and Q that was
fun and like bonding every night yeah it
was so great that was good it was it was
a good weekend I don't normally even
hang on begins nowadays but like we did
hang each night a little bit you know in
the room in the hotel and stuff hanging
not like going out but like I I did like
that you said entity before uh you
pronounced it perfectly but it made me
think like no one ever says entity
and it's the same exactly yeah but I'm
going to start saying entity
because it's funny because you're not
saying anything bad but you'll you will
throw the person off that you're talking
to Sure in that setting you know like if
I'm making a new LLC I need a new
business entity and if I said that to on
the zoom with the lawyers and accounts
and stuff please call it
and titty entity
[Laughter]
and to The Entity I don't know why it's
titty and titty
entity
if I said to you right now oh um it's a
whole different entity
would you say I wouldn't know what word
you were saying I swear to God I
wouldn't even know what word you were
saying entity it's so it's so weird how
subtle that difference in inflection is
yeah and yet it it flips the word on its
ear completely it literally wouldn't
know what word you were saying that's my
business entity
nice close your eyes uh can I talk to my
did that sound normal to you no because
now it sounds starting to sound normal
to me again
entity and titty you see the difference
it's hitting that second T entity it's
and or just pausing slightly at the end
entity
entity and titty see the difference and
titty is so much you say tit or tits do
you say do you say do you say tits or
titty titties
because I think I think you really I
think I think people latch on to one of
those one of those phrases like when
you're referring to breasts of of the
female variety are you saying oh it was
a nice tits it was a nice tit that's a
knife our tit fell out by accident uh it
was a nipples or do you say she's got
four examples please I'm not catching
the concept
like it's 1984. uh I I'd say tit I never
ever
say titties say titties or titties
such a funny one it's the trashiest
grossest way to say it it makes me sick
I have I have friends that exclusively
say it that way they're both I think
less of them I think both of them are
like arguably two of the most funny
words in the in the language of our but
I have friends that say it that's just
their word Jay oh Big Jay oakerson and
he's public about this I'm not talking
high school he says like titties and I'm
like what are you a a porn photographer
in the valley like what is wrong with
you like it's such a it's so gross I
don't think titties is in a dictionary I
don't think titty is because I tried uh
I tried titty on world it was like uh no
no no no spelling bee I'm spelling bee
and it didn't come out nobody said
titties since the editor of Swank
magazine like you know what I mean like
some guy with the Stefano glasses on
behind a desk with like those Boss Hog
horns
I am in the titty business
it is is more fun they're both fun
because tits has that curtiness to it
but titties is just fun it's stupid and
embarrassing it's silly but titty sounds
like a lot of titties like if you say oh
man I went in
tits were out I feel like that's one
person if you go there and be like oh
dude titties were out don't say the tops
down it sounds like hundreds of titties
right Nas you say oh yeah yeah you say
tits and you think it's a parrotids you
say titties you think it's like two
three hundred pairs of things
yes or no no I had to get out of it it
was titties everywhere
no yeah just do do not go in there
there's just titties everywhere you
wouldn't say if you still go in there if
you say there's titties everywhere then
that's very different yeah that made
that's insinuated and it's a lot but I'm
saying if I just hear the word in
general no I don't I don't think of like
mult I just think of if you say they got
tits out in there
I don't know I feel like tits is more
singular for some reason in my head
titty sounds like a party but it's way
better than breasts yeah breast sucks
breast is very biological I've noticed
uh and I don't know if um if I'm
accurate here in this but I think I am
women
that I know big upswing on boobs again I
feel like boobs is getting a lot
a lot of use these days Oh you mean
boobies
boobies is horrific boobies sounds like
you're in a third grade you know and
you're singing on a calculator yeah
cursed booby we're trying to limit them
apparently we're getting black from
people to not curse anyway uh just the
cashola and we're trying to make it so
that's what we're doing but this is kind
of interesting the uh what masturbation
actually means the word oh what does it
mean it's on it's on the screen oh in
other words translated literally
according to this Theory an
interpretation of masturbation could
well be to make one stupid by hand a
pretty damn accurate assessment I'm sure
you'll agree wow so long-standing
explanation is they said it's from like
ancient Greece and they they couldn't
figure out how this word was invented it
was just been passed linking the word
masturbation with the word for Turbo
Turbo
Mass
hand the mass syllable comes from a much
more ancient term for penis
which is mazdo
but little evidence exists to support
this it's a claim okay which is wild huh
it's just wild
like one like did you you could trace
each word back to like
you know like sometimes a particular
moment unless there was some group
thinking going on but like this stuff is
it's just it's always wild to me when I
think about words that's why I hate when
somebody
two two types of people do this people
will either there are people that will
misuse a word that will say what I'm
about to say
they'll purposefully misuse it to fit
their own needs
and then there's another type of person
that will use a really harsh
unsavory word and say they both will use
this excuse you'll say uh you're you
shouldn't say that word or
that's weird that you're using that term
incorrectly it actually means this
though both both people will go
though it's all language it's all
language nothing means what it used and
it's like shut up yeah shut up there's
got to be some boundary like or defining
you know what I mean yeah but it's
getting it's getting kind of crazy where
people are like it's crazy how misused
terms are just freely I know I feel like
we don't make new words anymore like I
feel like the things are added to the
ditch every year are like um slang
or or combinations of words that exist
is there like a a word Smith that is
creating words that is getting into the
who's Webster and why is he and who's
Miriam
um we should get to the battles where
are we at pimp
oh we gotta get to the battle okay okay
today's battle is pay-per-cut versus
stub toe which is worse uh I will be
defending stub toe as the worst of the
two Sal is taking on paper cut and it is
time to be ATT
I feel like we gotta get amped up a
little bit a song a salty
we've been trading Jabs okay now just
come on baby come on all right I yeah
you want to snap at me again you need
you need to have a dog you need to have
a salty
hey come on yeah all right
give us that you'll see someone snap at
a it's weird that you put your hair like
that time two
b-a-t-g-l-e Buzz
so you snuck in a salty without even the
thing of it
I had a hat on all day what do you want
from it
uh here's where I stuck toe is worse
no it's fine I'm joking all right it's a
stub toe you wouldn't do this I would
okay and you would get as equally
annoyed with me and this is why we'd be
a good married couple okay good uh you
see how he talks to me
I made this dinner by the way which was
for two when Kramer starts working at uh
Brian Leland that one's so great yeah
yeah I I don't we need to let you go I
don't even really work here yeah that's
what makes this so hard that's what
makes it so different that's what makes
it so difficult what's in your briefcase
crackers
I was referencing the not that there's
anything wrong with that episode
yeah I've been out of his ever end yeah
yeah when he when they're when they're
arguing and George Goes you see how he
talks to me
all right so I think Steptoe is worse
here's why
a stubbed toe
I mean look both of these are Shockers
but the initial pain of the stuffed toe
to me is far greater
than the initial pain of his paper cut
and though the pain of both Fades
there's one thing you can do with the
stub toe that is not even a variable
with a paper cut which is you can break
your toe I knew you're gonna pull that
out and I'm saying and I've done it in
my life I've stubbed my toe probably I
don't even know what let's call it in my
life 20 times I don't know maybe maybe
50 who would have 20. Jesus Lord 20 is
low dude a 50. I bet you it's in the
hundreds I'm sure I'd stub my toe once
or twice a year toe stubs are like I
feel like it's like one of those numbers
where they're like you touch your face
75 000 times a day you know what I mean
you're like I do I knew you were gonna
go to Breaking the foot and that is so
extreme not the foot the toe the toe
That's so exciting to me so I'm like I I
do agree that if you break your toe
stubbing a toe is worse and I think that
what you're gonna get from everybody is
what are you talking about you could
break your toe if you stub your toe and
that's going to lean on that but it's
like I was just having a conversation in
with Santino about
he's saying airplanes are the safest
thing in the goddamn world and I was
like no and he's like dude the
percentages of crashes versus flights is
insane and I feel like with the stubbed
toe the percentage that you break your
toe on a stubbed toe is extremely low
and so I don't want to hang the whole
battle on that what I feel about a stub
toe is yes in that moment I would say
stub toe in general might be more
painful I actually used to do a bit
where you like if you really want to get
to know a person and be around them when
they when they stub their toe and listen
to the words that come out of their
mouth because when people stub their toe
all bets are off yeah okay well then you
don't do that with a paper cut here's
the other thing that a paper cut won't
do
here's the other thing a paper cut won't
do this up till will which makes stuff
till worse in my opinion you stub your
toe you're hobbling around that room
you're doing a you're doing a skip for
20 seconds until it goes away it's it's
I'd say two good two minutes my issue
with the paper cut is that it lingers
and it keeps reopening over and over and
you get acid on it and you get to it and
it burns yeah like like I mean I like
lemon and I used to get little cuts off
if you're a bartender there's there's no
there's no uh I'm saying you could
squeeze a whole lemon stub toe no big
deal I mean once you have an open it's
an open wound versus hitting yourself
and then there's like walking it off but
with a paper cut especially if you get
it in a horrible place like a hand
that's active or a place that bends a
lot it just keeps reopening reopening
get infected it's burning you can have a
paper cut look at that you could have a
paper cut a week after you you cut your
hand look at this oh god oh see now
you're never gonna get a visceral
reaction like that from from talking
about a stubbed toe I'm looking at paper
cuts right on the edge of people these
are stubbed toes paper cut right on his
toe right there no these are stubbed
Toes that guy is literally missing half
a foot that's a stubbed toe accident
yes this is the worst of the worst with
stub toes and I literally give it to you
it's worse that's the worst thing I have
a break in the toe when you stop sorting
but it's it's not the normal it's not
the normal experience when you stub your
toe and so I just have to say like if
we're comparing them in general
like I stubbed my toe it hurts like a
[__] I hobble around a little bit I
skip it shakes off and I'm not gonna
stub my toe again for three months for
three years when we came out that's not
it's no it's not true it happens way
more than that I don't know I don't know
why you think it's so important for a
job or you're working with paper you can
have multiple paper cuts at a time and
as soon as it happens it's like the
paper card is like a Nails on a
chalkboard as soon as you hear that it's
summertime people that means Fun in the
Sun and Moon
answers here taste buds first Leaf
welcome to the show first Leaf is great
uh I love the summertime and I love
summertime activities you know barbecues
pool parties maybe you go camping
whatever it is it's always a good time
uh and for those occasions I'm somebody
that likes to have a bit of wine on the
ready ready to go uh and that's why I
like first Leaf first Leaf makes it
super easy to get personalized wine
boxes delivered on my schedule or your
schedule because you'll be ordering for
you not for me unless you want to order
for me uh since you get to choose the
day your shipment comes you can go out
have all your summer fun without
stressing about missing a delivery then
when you come home the Wine's there
arriving on the day you need it to
because you're there to receive it and
then you take it out with you on the
next outing or whatever it is get
started with first Leaf here's all you
got to do you answer some quick
questions about your likes your dislikes
on the website their expert team is
going to select a customized assortment
of world-class wine based on your
preferences personally
uh I do enjoy a rose in the summertime I
also like a crisp white but I also like
a nice red uh I'm a I'm a bit of a wine
uh Enthusiast if you will but I also
have a picky palette not an advanced
palette but a picky palette and I like
that the quiz and answering these
questions is helping me get the stuff
that I want because I know what I like
and I'm gonna get that plus I'm also
getting first leaves 100
satisfaction guarantee I love this make
sure you got great wine when you want it
this summer you go to First Leaf so just
head on over to try firstleaf.com that's
t-r-y-f-i-r-s-t-l-e-a-f.com slash taste
buds you're gonna sign up there and
you're gonna get your first six hand
curated bottles for just 44.95 that's
incredible you don't get six bottles of
wine that are good or decent or worth
your time for 44.95 trust me this is a
great deal go and try first Leaf at try
firstleaf.com taste buds again try
firstleaf.com taste buds that's
t-r-y-f-i-r-s-t-l-e-a-f.com slash taste
buds your first six bottles for under
eight dollars a bottle firstleaf.com
taste buds folks game
game one of the regular sponsors here at
the taste buds podcast game time is a
great app uh when you want to get those
last minute tickets for any sort of
event whether it's Sports whether it's
music
theater whatever game time is going to
help you get those tickets for the best
prices available they're going to get
you the best seats available uh and
you're gonna get get all this done
headache free that's the great thing
about game time if you want to go to an
event and you know
you don't always have the time to plan
months in advance uh things come up
things happen sometimes you just need to
go when you need to go and when you need
to go you end up a lot of the time
stressing out about getting the right
tickets are these any good am I getting
ripped off can we see from where the
seed is blah blah blah game time is
taking care of all of that they've got
views from the seats so you can see
exactly what it's going to look like
when you sit down uh it's the lowest
price guarantee as I said uh there's
event cancellation protection there's
job loss protection uh this is the place
to go and and Game Time guarantees
that you'll always get the best price if
you find tickets in the same section and
row for less money game time will credit
you 110
110 of the difference that's amazing
anyway download the game time app create
an account use promo code taste buds for
twenty dollars off your first purchase
terms apply again create an account and
redeem code taste buds for twenty
dollars off download game time today
last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed folks Joe DeRose here from
the taste buds podcast I got live shows
coming up and you're going to get all
the info and tickets for those live
shows at joederrosa.com where am I going
to be September 16th Avenal New Jersey
at the Avenal Performing Arts Center
September 21st and 22nd Toronto in
Canada at the JFL just for laughs
Festival in Toronto Las Vegas Nevada
September 24 29th through October 1st at
skank Fest and then the big one
Philadelphia PA November 11th theater of
the Living Arts that's the big Hometown
show again get your tickets at
joederrosa.com all right and if you need
more of me as you wait with baited
breath to see me live doing I Never
Promised You a Rose Garden you can head
now to wherever you get digital music to
hear my new record the penthouse paper
selected readings it's me reading all
the op-eds I did for Penthouse magazine
for a few years none of the Rose Garden
material but a whole bunch of other
material that's with a special thing
records again wherever you get your
digital music it's available now and
last but not least if you're in New York
City come see us at Joey roses have a
sandwich have a drink joyrozesnyc.com
hello guys and I just want to give you
some dates right now the very last
weekend of the Joker's tour for now the
first leg is happening July 27th uh 28th
and 29th we're at Nashville at the Grand
Ole Opry Cambridge field house uh in
Indianapolis and the stifle theater for
two shows on the 29th in St Louis those
are available at
impracticaljokerslive.com come the New
Year we will be adding the second leg of
this tour so if you didn't see us yet
don't fret uh other than that the reason
we are shifting is because I am going
back on the second leg of my solo tour
and I am filming a special in December
at the Vic Theater in Chicago Chicago
and Chicago's surrounding greater
metropolitan area I chose you come out
and support your boy
um leading up to that I will be at the
Hartford Funny Bone in August I will be
at the Syracuse Funny Bone in September
I will be at the there was another Funny
Bone in there and I don't remember uh
Albany the Albany Funny Bone in August
as well and then we're doing Bowling
Green Kentucky Cincinnati Ohio Toledo uh
Wilkes bar bear I never know guys I'm
sorry in Pennsylvania Wilmington
Delaware uh Macon Georgia Savannah
Georgia Athens Georgia Peoria Illinois
Rockford Illinois Cedar Rapids Iowa
Springfield Illinois and then I'm doing
a very special one-night warm-up show
right before the special in Elkhart
Indiana at the Lerner Theater those
tickets if not yet are going to be on
sale very soon at savocano comedy.com
pay attention to my socials because I'm
going to Tweet all the pre-sale stuff to
get the best tickets first uh that's
pretty much it check out my merch and
check out the podcast merch go to
samlican.com
uh Jokers are starting up again season
10 the second half of that Thursday
nights at 10 on TBS and True TV I love
you I will see you on the road I'm very
excited thank you
there here's the thing there are two
different types of pain
you know toe stub is Homer Simpson oh
daughter you know dope pain
paper cut is
you know what I was saying I feel like
it's Nails on a chalkboard I recoil at
the thought of a paper cut like I bang
my arm into something I bang it's just
this is just banging your toe into
something
piercing flesh drawing blood and an open
wound that needs to heal the thing I
don't like about the paper cut
apparently is that it it lingers
especially if it's in an inopportune
place if it's somewhere on your hand
knuckle you know your knee your leg
whatever you need but like
it's going to open every time you move
your hand and it's going to take you
know a week two weeks to heal and it's
going to be nagging and annoying three
days a little Neosporin no I don't know
three days I think it could go longer
than that but my point is it does longer
more if you're not breaking your foot on
a stubbed toe you're gonna shake that
off in about a minute or two so I mean
which one would I rather do I don't want
to break my toe in that respect you got
me dead to rights but that's such a
small percentage that I don't want to
hang the battle on that and so if I'm
looking at your average experience with
both
oh man a paper could just the thought of
it makes me like go a stub toe doesn't
do that you know what I mean I think
that you're just slitting through your
skin at like these little it's just so
gross I I think I'm seeing a lot of I'm
seeing a lot I mean maybe I miss looking
here
or misjudging rather but it
it looks like there's a lot of paper cut
yeah uh
paper cut
is a short sharp shock
oh but no this is pro the first one I
read is Prost up to uh but the stuff
toes got you hopping around in agony
forever
chapstick can fix a paper cut in a few
seconds when I step my toe I have to get
in the fetal position that's a great
Point I've never heard that in my entire
life never heard one single person say
put chapstick on a paper cut ever ever
have you have you
no but that's about 120 years of life
here but that's not but that's not
that's not the point that I was saying
is a good point okay uh you know I I
equate a ChapStick to Neosporin or
whatever I mean I I think she's saying
you put petroleum jelly on it you're
nursing a wound though you got to put a
bandage on because you're gonna get it
wet or not are your points you're
applying ointment now you're in the hole
for seven eight dollars you don't have
to put a bandage on it oh you do I never
I never to stop leading to keep it from
opening every time you touch it I gotta
be honest with you I have shelterly have
had a paper cut bleed maybe a Teensy bit
of blood to the surface initially but
that that that's gone very quickly and
I've I can't remember the last time I
put a Band-Aid on a paper cut in fact
most places I would argue on because
paper cuts it's it's hands let's let's
not pretend like we're getting them in
other places
most of the places on the hand that you
would get a paper cut you can't put a
Band-Aid anyway you know like like
unless that's just why it's terrible
right on the right scenario but my point
is is like there's no real bandaging and
all that you put a little Neosporin on
it it's usually gone in a few days
um that's a pain in the ass I think the
matter is though you know you're tending
to an open cut that's lasting days and
could reopen and is nagging and is
annoying and you know like go ahead I'm
sorry no I was just saying like I when I
look at both at face value if I'm not
breaking my toe I'll just stress that
one more time I'm gonna go
jump around a bit rub it a little bit in
about a minute two minutes tops after I
am it never happened
well you know what I think is worse than
a paper cut a bad hang nail
oh that's bad a bad hang now or even
cutting that's the worst of all of them
I think even cutting uh a fingernail too
low or toenail too low oh that to me is
worse than a paper cut now look we
should do hang nail versus bee sting no
hang nails worse hangnail is terrible
it's the worst it beats everybody
do you think it beats bee sting yeah oh
wow I put a pin in that all right all
right all right
um but
oh I can't let's see I can't even look
at it I can't even look at it but I'll
watch Stevo stub his toe all day long
he's opening they did it but hold on
they jackass they did the worst version
of it they did the webbing of their
fingers and toes it's yes that makes me
cringe too oh God that's like this is
this is the the paper cut equivalent to
on jackass they hit their toe with a
hammer and it was called the toaster you
know what I mean like they're make
they're doing it so awful but yeah it's
terrible yeah Stevo at one point does it
to the corners of his mouth yeah it's
horrible
it's horrible
um
but you know uh uh it's I I I think on
visceralness alone just puts you down
dude it's like I can't I see red when I
here's what I would say
paper cut I'm annoyed God damn it now I
gotta deal with this stub toe I'm angry
okay I'm angry at God when it happens
okay why are you doing this to me right
now okay and you don't get angry or God
with the paper cut no with a paper cut
it's more like a like a like a dog that
won't start barking where it's like uh
great great thing it's an annoying yes
that's how I that's how I see it I I if
I think of the two of them one makes me
shudder that's got to be the one that I
think is worse right
I don't know because it's it's this is
what's so hard about this one is because
paper cut is length
I think you would shudder if if jackass
did some variation of a stubbed toast on
I think you would also go oh like it's
yeah but but you know what I mean it has
that quality of like uh
when you get shocked when you when you
you know you buy tinfoil or when you
hear screeching yes it's got that like
oh God please stop please make it to the
butt stub toe has the quality of hit
your hit your thumb with the hammer when
you're nailing so yeah
you don't break your thumb when you do
that when you do that you're like oh my
God you know it's a good one finger
that's a good one hit the thumb with a
hammer versus something finger in the
car door
oh god dude my friend I was on a road
trip in 2003 to New Orleans and we had a
minivan and Brian Johnson yeah our buddy
Brian Johnson shout out Brian lead
singer of AC DC correct yeah our buddy
from comic book man and tell them Steve
Davis Tom Steve Dave and and more
um
he I was getting out so I I was getting
out of the back so I held on to that you
know like the where the where the the
divider between the front door and the
back door is I held that and he got out
of the front door and slammed the door
shut and my all four of my fingers were
in the door all four and the door closed
fully
and I just yelled and I was like open
the door open the door
it just felt like my head was being
crushed and he's like oh and he opened
it and I just looked in my hand it was
like it literally was a divot across all
four fingers it's like indented and
already black and blue and I was like oh
my God oh my God the only thing that
saved me was the fact that there was
like that stripping yeah otherwise I
literally it was bad now you know what
he did immediately
he just mocked me immediately
and he and to this day it's 20 years
that we went April in April 2003 20
years later he'll go he'll say one time
look at me go open the door open the
door my hand open the door like making
fun of my accent I guess but it it's a
it's a pain I've never lost I once
closed the TR
I once
she left I once slammed the shower door
the car truck
and my dad's head was in the way oh no
and like the latch kid
oh
[Laughter]
he was he was cracking up
he was so hurt
why is that so funny we did you know
somebody that's Three Stooges so it is
we did a we did a monologue when I wrote
for the Pete home show called oops
comedy and it I told Pete that story and
I was laughing this hard and he was like
we got to do a monologue called oops
comedy like you step on the rake it hits
you in the head like the thing falls off
the shelf onto your head like it's so
funny finger in the car door was one
like it's so funny and I think we even
we said in it it's like three stooges
like yeah it's just so fun oh my God I
teared up I was laughing so hard
um
oh my God it's just it's just very funny
stuff continue with the phones here I
don't know who's gonna win this I think
you are because I think people are gonna
be like you break your toe stop telling
no I'm not I haven't seen that once I'm
I'm that that's the first broken toe one
I just saw from Shan here but I'm seeing
a lot of okay yeah Parker says stub my
toe off a radiator and broke it uh never
broke a bone from paper cut clear winner
the next person is I have a scar from a
gnarly paper cut but never from a
stubbed toe stop till pain goes away
after a while Joe paper cut is lasting
effect that's very funny like that
they're addressing it paper cut lives on
forever give me a stub toe any day
I hope they understand it they're
choosing the one that is worse I think I
think they do
so if you have a higher percentage of
stub toe I win
you understand
no yes I just hope you're voting for the
one that's worse right so whatever
higher percentage one wins oh yeah what
am I thinking I don't know you're saying
paper cut is worse so it would have a
higher percentage okay vote for that
okay yeah it's still the same the cut
I'm seeing a lot of the cut last long in
a world oversaturated hand sanitizer
like this paper cuts make you suffer
more than just once that is a great
point that was what I thought Citrus
yeah hand sanitizer sure that's wait can
you scroll back one second a little more
so she says here uh I like the way she
worded this stub toe is horrid but horid
but pain last minute paper cut will
remind you who the boss is every chance
it can get I I I I see here's the thing
with the paper cut though once if you're
not hand sanitizing
or dealing in Citrus
you you can forget about the paper cut
pretty quick I mean it's not like it's
not like it's reopening to a in a way
every day that you're going oh my God it
hurts but it is and I'm always sucking
on it and like like it's like it's not
like do you ever crack a fingernail like
I'd adores my aunt's door slammed on my
thumbnail and it broke my thumbnail in
half losing a thumb losing a nail oh
that was a throbbing pain that's a
combination almost with these two things
together that was a throbbing pain that
literally woke me from sleep at times it
was it hurt for days and days and days
that's not the way a paper cut is
reopening is my point you know I get
that it lasts longer but anyway
uh paper cut is the equivalent telling
you they're not mad just disappointed in
you
a stub toe is equivalent of dropping a
slice of pizza on the floor I kind of
get what he means by that
excuse me imagine each one apricots are
fun because you get to see inside your
skin I do agree with that imagine each
one which one can make you feel more
vividly in your mind it's paper cut
every time when I stub my toe I make
myself sit in it as I scream expletives
and tell myself I deserve it for not
paying attention but paper cuts are
worse I think paperwork's going to take
this the thought of stubbing my toe
doesn't cause me the same emotional
damage as the idea of a paper cut
WoW paper cuts continue to hurt well
after the initial cut
I once got a paper cut under my
fingernail oh yeah
paper cut hurts much longer when you
forget about it boom man you're gonna
take this WOW damn it you're gonna take
it I thought I thought you had I thought
it was going to be all hello you could
break your footstubbing I thought I'd
get a little traction on that too but we
got 10 000 votes here and it's lean in
paper pie ten thousand votes uh pimpy is
choosing stub toe
whoa whoa oh
my closest ever no we had a tie once oh
yeah we did we had a tie once I mean
this is insane if it went a little
longer it could go anyone's way yeah
you're right stub toe wins
with
50.7 to paper cuts
49.3 we split that last percentage point
that is wild
dude that's crazy now I'd like to point
out
in the middle of this episode because
pimp needed a memory card that he didn't
have yeah and he left had that not
happened you might have won this
I wish you could have checked what it
was like an hour ago wow that's that
that's rematch territory what's even
more crazy is that it was 90 90 plus
percent paper cut in the in the phone on
the phone that's what I wonder if people
commenting aren't always voting because
that's happened a couple times now and
it's happened to your favor there have
been a couple times where we've read
comments and I've been like holy God I
I'm gonna take this 100 and then I lose
I hope I I want to know okay can you go
back to that pimp the percentages here's
what I hear is what I'm just gonna I'm
gonna posture okay
I think inevitably even if it's very
minute there is a small percentage of
people
who
inadvertently said I'd rather have a
stubbed toe than a paper cut
and clicked on stub toe
the winning percentage is so small that
I wonder if that played any Factor but
that being said it would be the same in
Reverse right you have someone being
like I'd rather have a I'd rather have a
paper cut sure so maybe that washes
itself out this is crazy man by the
phones I thought you were gonna get
trounced let's make a note trust is a
fun one this has to be a rematch
somewhere down the line I mean that's so
close people don't say trounced enough
trounced yeah oh I don't
it's like I must know the word but I
don't know like if I if I blew out like
oh I'm gonna trounce on that yeah or do
you say well I can try like a drubbing
or dropping those two words never really
get used like if you beat me 90 to 10
that was a drumming you trounced me
I jesus dude I would have up until you
just said that to me thought trounced
meant pounced
like I'm gonna pounce on that I don't
believe so can you Google trounced
you're making me second guess myself
I no I don't I think just because of the
sound of it I thought that yeah defeat
heavily all right well buddy I still
love you I love you too
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them